running late
okay all right relative to 1018 Rel to
on premise off prevence liquor
licenses there's an amendment
right is this this oh this okay
okay all
right so last the last amendment I have
is
0110 is that are we is that the right
one
yeah are you foll me along with
everything we need to do is
am
this one says January 10th right no
there's another we we don't have it
yet I got
it I have that one but there's another
one that came in yeah that's that's the
one that's January 10th another one
that's the last time we met they were
going to get another amendment what was
the other Amendment going to be about it
was just cleaning up the um second uh
license
Lang license is still on on o on
1018 it's on the second
page
line
18 in the original Bill
original I don't I don't think any of us
have that amendment I don't think we
have the amendment you have anything on
1018 maybe Carrie
um did did they bring the files out did
you get the files no but I had this but
this is this was in my file we held this
last week and liqu commissioner will
submit an amendment and okay I don't see
that you said you
sent is it it could be in the file
that's the that's what I'm
thinking
no I got the we got the January that's
it yeah right yeah there's nothing
no I haven't seen
anything
I oh
there's I
have it's just
adding
okay there's another there's going to
need to be one yes okay so we'll move on
from that
one all
right6 okay 1076 so where are we with
1076 there was amendment subm to allow
for the
manufactur the same premise manufactur
LIC manufa
ret
okay this is why I have subcommittees I
there's too much going on I can't keep
track of it all right so we're going to
look in the file again in that
one yeah we're going to skip over 1018
because we still need another amendment
drawn up on that
one yeah yeah so that's what we're
that's where we're hopefully going to
get done this morning um and then take
up everything that doesn't get done
today um it'll be March 5th Tuesday
March
5th Pi it chairman I have a copy of this
well
okay or is it no it's it's a
but she
has
so 1076 we're going to um add beverage
manufacturers to the same same statute
same concept for the wine manufacturer
license right exactly
okay
okay all right so move move on to the
next one all right 11:51 relative to
carrying alcohol beverages on Hotel
premises okay so
um okay
so okay so this
one this one uh is going to we're gonna
we're calling this the
Frankenstein what we're going to do with
this one is we're going to solve several
problem so we had the other bill that
had the uh
artists
artists mus musician y oh yes
right
1582 no that's where they can drink
while they're CLE the right and and we
also is on areas designated for the end
entertainers so that means u in the
green
room um okay then we have so yeah so
Roman three is that Roman numeral
four is about allowing you to
carry and okay so iume people in the
audience might want to see
this
problem about the that statute right now
say commiss report
daily and but they have a joy monthly
all along so stuck
do you guys have
this
think
bottom um I I I believe a oh
good
aot we want everybody at home okay great
happy to
help so your question
was approved areas where would not be
would where would areas not be approved
yep essentially okay my understanding is
where areas would not be approved would
be something like
bathrooms
um I guess May and it would a parking
lot well Ted technically you can't go
outside the four walls of the buildings
even with this bill so I would assume
that that would mean no parking lots um
I'm think the bathroom was done by rule
the department did that by rule they
didn't even do we didn't actually have a
statue about the bathroom right but no I
don't think any business would want to
be able to have a drink in the bathrooms
anyway that's just going to lead to
problems right um what about
Lobby so I think that's where it gets
interesting because if I'm coming from a
restaurant and I walk through the lobby
to get to the elevator or whatever it
might be
I would think that would be an approved
area under this change so next is the
paragraph
four and I apologize I'm running late so
I haven't read this good got some
ex can hear you breathing hard those
stairs are tough when you're running up
them I
know so F first thought is is to the
number of registered guests to that room
so there aren't is only usually one
registered guest in any given room right
whoever books the room and I I don't
think there would be any scenario where
a hotel would necessarily ask for the
list of names of people that are staying
in any given room so that would be
really hard to enforce my hotel a little
dicks Bay there in Virgin Gorda wants to
know who else is in the room interesting
yeah I mean this we're talking about a
festar hotel and they want to know the
spouse's name well well yes but that's
more for you know your spouse's name so
they can personalize their service to
you but the average hotel um likely
would not ask for that information and
then it gets into the whole weird thing
about well if you list the children who
are under the age of 21 is this now a
privacy concern or issue blah blah blah
blah blah so it starts to spiral into a
place that I don't know that we want to
go
frankly other than that I think you know
you're talking about partially consumed
bottle of wine from the lounge to the
guest room I think that's okay I think
that's frankly I think that could
technically be allowed on the current
statute with the whole leaving of a
restaurant with a open bottle of wine
that's properly packaged Etc in this
case we're just not asking for it to be
packaged so I think that's
reasonable what other questions can I
answer everybody sure so uh you know
somebody
having you put your sound on yeah you
put your mic on please I'm just thinking
about um how you would in if if you to
have parties you could say look you can
be drinking but after 12 parties over
you know something like that because
there are other people in the on the in
the hallway and well that goes back to
there's another part of title 13 and and
look enforcement could speak to this
better than I but it's the control of
your premise right so you have to have
control of your premise you can't let
things just kind of get out of hand and
go crazy I would also suspect that an
average hotel if somebody was being loud
or going too late they're going to get
complaints at the front desk they're
going to shut it down anyway so I don't
know that that's really something you
want to necessarily address in statute
but operationally that's exactly what
would happen all right and then you know
another area that occurs to me that
maybe your a hotel would not want to
allow drinking drinks an unapproved area
I'm thinking if they have a hotel pool
or an exercise room something like so I
think there would be scenarios where
they would not want it to be um
essentially allowed to have have alcohol
in those
areas right so you leave it up to the
discretion of the owner I think so yeah
because I think most businesses are
going to make this the smart choices for
themselves and their liability insurance
frankly
right
okay all right thank you good all right
so as I said uh this bill has three
parts to it now it's going to have uh
the underlying Bill
1151 and it has um now it has
1582 and then the third part is is just
that loose end that came up with the
public hearing on the bill we've already
passed out a committee which is the uh
the uh Liquor Commission Bill and that
was where the daily the month issue got
solved so that's section two of the
bill okay uh anybody in the audience
have a problem with anything you see
here see none okay anybody in the
committee have any
questions
yes so we'll we'll be we can vote on
this this piece yes yes we can well
there'll be a voting 1151 then when we
get to 1152
1582 we'll just interim study that so in
case something were to happen to this
bill we could but the the number of
registered guests bother me I stay at
pretty decent hotels I travel constantly
no one has ever asked for my name so
that means I would never be allowed I
would never show up as registered and
therefore could never have a
drink this is it it's it's not written
at the end of the day you could go down
with your spouse and go get the drink
the issue was the question was uh you
know how many people are going down and
grabbing a
drink but that's not what it says right
what what part are you you're concerned
about I'm looking at line
16 okay for the purpose of this
paragraph the number of alcohol beverage
shall be limited to the number of
registered guests to that room who are
age 21 age years older Believe It or
Not hotels very much want to know how
many people they're in or they do count
the number of people but count that's
all that that's all it's
saying
register well shall be limited to the
number of registered guests so the
register is when you or when you book a
room you tell them how many people in
that's no you don't usually no no excuse
me excuse me let's let's clarify what
the word registered means in your mind
registered means they have my name no no
I I'm sorry John that excuse me okay so
what do you think registered means
so when it says double
occupancy what would you write if you
were on a
booked package they would ask for how
many occupancy but if you are going on
your own you know husband wife going on
your own they don't usually ask I have
never been asked my husband has never
been asked believe it or not you are you
you are booking the room based on double
occupancy whether I know it or not
whether you knew it or not
exactly okay if you say so you learn
something new every day every
day they well let me put it this way I
don't know that they actually change the
price between a single occupy and double
occupany but they ask it just so to get
clear maybe you know the industry can
tell us why why they insist on asking
because I think they're more worried
about whether you go beyond the
two that's when that's you know when the
can of worms start opening up and so uh
I would say is that but that the
Assumption most of the time when you do
that booking if you were actually to
print it out and read the fine print
it'll it'll say double double occupancy
now I would know uh pretty much every
every web page I've ever seen they the
first thing they ask you is how many
people gu
you do it online right's a lots to do
it uh if you call on the phone that may
be true they might not ask you but I I I
don't know I I I can't say but I'll okay
good we I'll tell you what we can you
can uh we can write that in the blurb to
make clarify
that that is the legislative intent that
that covers double occupancy
okay all right so who's on this
subcommittee now right here
okay post car's taking burs okay SPI is
not okay but when you say Carrie you
meant
spear he gave me Spear's name but she's
not on like girl I know but you're
saying she replaced barrows Carrie
replaced Barrows okay yeah but he told
me that spear was on alol I said okay no
I got no I got that right just said you
wrote her first name here in last yeah
okay okay and then who's this six seven
that's okay okay so who who do we have
here let's confirm see who's actually
here we have pusk we could do some cross
so we have pusk is here Walsh Walsh is
here Hunt is here post is not post is
not so those three and then okay and
then car is here for um right and
Sullivan is
here Sullivan is
here so now we have six without exactly
do that yes that's what I want to do so
we're we're going to be six six of us
for voting purposes okay um all right
all those in and support of the
amendment of
so you got your glasses today I
do and moved by uh six representative
pusk okay
perfect okay all uh
any anybody have anything they want to
say about 1151 if not uh all those in
favor please raise your hand one two
three four five six six zip okay
representative pusc second represent
bullo moves ought to pass as
amended okay all those in favor say
I those post so move
y
okay
all
right 12 extending the hours sales for
on
um
okay okay um I assume you're going to be
the you're going to want to pass this
right and I'm I'm I'm opposed to it
because I just don't think there's a
need for it we're we're not New York
we're not New York we're not what we're
not New York well I mean this we don't
have to stay open to 4 a.m. and that's
on what this does no I see 3: a.m. 2 2
a.m. I say 3 a. 2 am. 2 amm 3: a.m. if
if 2: am is a current law No 2 am is the
current law if they opt in this will
allow any town in the state to be 2:
a.m. 3:00 a.m. is if you opt in so this
basically puts us in line
with the majority of States we are in a
small minority right now and so that
that's I think it's a I think it's a
good reasonable Bill to kind of
modernize the way we are this isn't
making us New York or Vegas or anything
like that right but the the question is
okay in terms of and so I did a ton of
research on this like looking at
academic papers and studies and the
results are pretty mixed like the idea
that there's all sorts of problems that
come from extended
hours there is no consensus on that
there's been a bunch of studies from
Ontario I can read through them all
Ontario California um and there Ireland
uh England and extending hours is very
mixed in some cases it leads to more
problems in some cases it actually leads
to fewer problems so there is no
consensus amongst the academic literat
and I just think it's I think this is a
good step to
modernize and make us more in line we're
one of okay here's my here's my
compromise here's my compromise is that
um so right
now the LI I see I see what I was look
the lcy May sell to two if the town
voted for it so you want to add that to
another hour no that's not the part I
care so much about um we can leave that
you can take that out if you want well
well I want to take out what I want to
take out is on the premise may sell from
6:00 AM to 1 a I want that to be the
standard so no I want that to I want I
want that to be the standard but that if
the license he wants to sell
Beyond 1:00
a.m. and you could say up to 3:00
a.m. then that has to be voted on by the
town so reason I'm doing this just so
you know is that there's an economic
impact here and that's law called law
enforcement and so therefore it's an
economic impact to the state because it
means that that we we're having our
liquor our liquor enforcement has to be
stay up late and we have and have to
have extra hours and could be overtime
hours which could be even more money
okay so I I'm just saying is is that if
you if you want as my spirit of
compromise that LE the current law at
the 1:00 a.m. but that if you want to go
add extra hours it needs to be voted on
by the town so my spirit of compromise
would be the opposite let's let's keep
let's move to two and we could take off
to 3:00 am. so that it's just
two okay that's now we have two differ
opinions on this let's ask committee
members what do you think I I don't
think we should be I don't think we
should be I will tell you if the Senate
sees that 2 am. I know
they're going to kill a lot of things
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't start
the discussion because at the end of the
day New Hampshire is well let's go for
for let's let's just know I'm not let's
just challenge them and see what they do
with it I'm not even I'm not even doing
that I'm not even advocating for that
what I am now if you think fine let's
let's turn into a New Orleans be open
all night or Vegas I mean I'm not that's
that's not what I'm trying to do I'm not
trying to turn us into New York or Vegas
or New Orleans I'm just trying to make
us more in line with our competitive
States so Vermont allows to their
society hasn't crumbled Massachusetts
does too their society hasn't crumbled I
mean Most states have we are one of 10
states that doesn't go to 2 2 a.m. okay
I know for a fact that Cambridge closes
at
1 well maybe have the option maybe
Cambridge does I I don't think actually
that is not true I've live there and
I've been out to 2 a.m. in Cambridge no
I always we always had to go from
Cambridge when was this John well
70s okay yeah so I liveed there in the
2010s and I can tell you it was open
till 2 that they moved it to two that's
because they were probably they were
tired people leaving town do you want me
to leaving you like me to take you to
Cambridge and show you how how vibrant
it is at 2 a.m. I mean come on like it's
it's it's not a big deal it's it's not
going to be the end of the world the the
academic studies which I spent hours
researching shows that this is not a big
deal and yes it it might require
changing around Resources with respect
to law enforcement but like that doesn't
necessarily mean they have to spend more
money they can like just reshift
scheduling like you could have fewer
people on at a different hour or sh
start things like there's there are
flexible ways you can do
this 40 states do this the Hampshire's
not going to crumble if we if we become
more modern it's not about crumbling I
mean Hello we haven't passed the
marijuana we're the only state in New
England hasn't pass the marijuana have
we crumbled no we are but people don't
want to pass it cuz they appear seem to
think that we will crumble if we do pass
it this seems to be the fearmongering
that drives all this sort of stuff
represent Wallace what would you like to
do yeah but what time to the towns have
to get to okay so you're okay with the
bill as it is written okay
representative pus do you have an
opinion of course I have an
opinion I would be remiss if I
didn't um I like the idea of leaving it
at one and with the
option uh to go to three on by local
conditions or local uh folks okay so
right now we have
three two so representa spe you're the
you're the deciding vote
did you ask me what's that did you ask
me no you said you you agreed with him
yeah I kind of like the idea that the
town should pick right but but at what
time do the town should pick starting at
I don't they could pick any time as far
as I'm concerned if the town agrees to
four o'clock in the morning I don't care
oh as long as the town decides yes we
can handle it well that's a whole
another question where's my liquor guy
can a
town have set an ordinance and and and
shut liquor stores down earlier than one
bars in our current law Li stores bar no
no
barss yep sure why can't the owner shut
it down what well the owner could shut
it
down requiring this is just enabling we
like enabling right yes we liquor
enablers are not supposed to be good
people we' already passed few enabling a
lot of just no that's not the word you
want to
use thank you chairman and committee
members the way the statute reads now is
it's RSA 17917 hours of sale it says uh
on premises licenses may sell from 6:00
a.m. to 1:00 a.m. 7 days a week the
lensey May sell until 2 a.m. under
conditions authorized by the legislative
body of the city or town in which the
premise are located if the legislative
body adopts an ordinance authorized such
sales right so the question I'm asking
is can a
town um have an an or an an ordinance
that says we want the bars to close at
one if we were to pass this let's say
let's say for right now could they have
them could a town pass an ordinance to
shut the bars down at
midnight I suppose they could do that um
I
I'm not sure
any legislative body local legislative
body that has done that and and quite
honestly right now we only have three
jurisdictions in the state um that have
opted to stay open until 2
a.m. and those are Berlin lonia only on
we's Beach and NASA and in NASA it's
only for the charitable gaming
licenses so there's very few community
is even using the 2:00 so your hopes of
getting this
in
Littleton Beth
a't I mean why can't why is it why can't
it be this is the default and if the
local towns don't like it they can
always that was that's my art what I'm
saying is that is that as long as the
town local town could pass an ordinance
and say we want to stay at 1:00 a.m.
then then I I have no I have no argument
oh yeah if we if we you want to write it
that way I'm fine so if the town truly
is against it then they can they can be
on record saying we're against it but
the default in the state should be twoo
I'm fine with that compromise okay legis
by in which the premis
located
um oh all right fine let's just pass
let's just pass this since it's going to
kill it anyways but okay all right
that's
fine
right okay so representative
Sullivan want a second
W yeah well
okay move thought to pass any discussion
on the
motion uh all those in favor say
I one two three four five okay that is
zip nope and those
opposed two SEC so it's five to
one
okay all right relative to contract
manufacturing of beer Wine and Liquor so
this is the one we have to still do more
work
on
okay all right so we'll take this up
later
needs
Amendment okay so what is the problem
just so we all know what the problem is
problem it's yeah sorry why don't you
just stay
there thank you chairman and committee
members
the the issue here is this is very
technical changes in the bill allowing
uh the liquor manufacturers and the wine
manufacturers the privilege to enter
into contract brewing and tenant Brewing
or tenant manufacturing contract
manufacturing Arrangements like the the
uh beverage manufacturers have been
allowed to do and doing so there's
there's is a lot of legislative change
in this the issue right now that is
being discussed is getting the language
around the bever the uh
contract uh manufacturing definition in
the contract manufacturing Arrangement
correct in the years past and when the
legislation was initially passed that
language was opposite of what the uh um
Federal standard is and their
understanding of a contract um agreement
and a contract
manufacturer so it all comes down to who
is the the contract and who is the
Brewer and that's what we're trying
trying to solidify to make sure it's
right
okay any questions from anybody so the
bill is is we're no we're still needs
more Amendment we're still because we're
trying we're trying to take care of the
wine guys we are currently working with
the New Hampshire Brewers Association to
make sure that this is this is uh right
as you know they're the ones that
entered the original bill for the
beverage manufacturers
right okay good all right next one so
then needs Amendment next one is 1374 re
relative to liquor license for
restaurants since you are so friendly on
this last bill I'm happy to just put
this into instrum study if you'd like
really yes oh okay in the spirit of
compromising cooperation that you're so
good
at okay representative
Sullivan seconded by representative hunt
Moose uh 137 four will be interim
study I just want to mention that in
2017 you
were uh interviewed by nhpr and I it's
it's you're really for this in in 2017 I
wish you still were today really for
what for this
bill it's not the same bill but it's
very similar similar yeah okay
yeah
Y no not yet yeah we're voting okay
interim study interim study all right
any discussion on the motion of interim
study seeing none all those in favor of
inter room study please raise your hand
two three four five six
zip okay
all right now we get some heated moments
here all right HB 1380 relative to uh
Brew Pub
licenses
okay
but
so okay so um we if you all remember
last week we had a long discussion about
the underlying issue
here and um it's the beer
distributors and who want very much to
uh do not want us to pass this bill and
they wanted us to do the uh allow this
lensey to go forward as a nano even
though he's clearly not an Nano and and
be a nano for for whatever hour that we
want him to be an a nano for an hour and
then assuming that we're going to pass
the Senate bill um change it um is so
just to tell everybody my I have spent a
lot of time dwelling on this issue and
my initial reaction to it when I first
heard about the bill the issue um is
still my my reaction today so from 2017
to wherever I am on this bill hasn't
really changed and that is that um The
brw Hub is the is has always been the
ultimate um anti three- tier statue
right out of the G it's it's it's
through three tier in the trash can they
try to somewhat uh go through the
motions by saying well the Brew Pub is
really a beverage manufacturer that just
happens to have a license to to you know
an off Prem you know the on- premise
license but in the end of the day I I
don't see that at all when I go to a brw
hub to me um uh it's a restaurant that
just happens to make its own be
and uh and and the idea that we can that
if you make your own beer and you own
multiple restaurants you should sell be
able to sell it well you can because we
in that other build that contract Brew
which we still have a little issues on
it but that's what they do but the idea
of they making it on your home or your
own home recipe um it's like uh uh
you're a pie shop and you're making your
own pies rather than buying you know and
I just think that uh the one thing I
would change is I uh in the bill on line
8 um I would reduce that 5,000 to
2500 um and that way it is a that 2500
is a very dominous number that is what
exactly what the Brew Pub is allowed to
do now so if they didn't if they get
Beyond this 2500 then yeah they're
goingon to have to contract Brew you
know they're not going to be making it
in the in that in that restaurant uh
they've got to they've got to they've
got to think bigger and better at that
point and use the contract Bru statute
yes repr spear the 2500 is that per year
per per year per
year so by reducing that that's
allowing Michael Timothy to be able to
do what he want so Michael Timothy would
would could certainly work with this
with with 2500 yeah do you think
yeah okay now I I realize you know
Scott's not going to be happy and uh and
he he can take up the battle on the
Senate side but at this point um that's
that's that's what I feel I'm I'm
recommending we do but uh um I'm willing
to listen to anybody wants to argue with
my with my logic but it's just that I
think that
um The Brew Pub The Brew Pub if you know
if they have multiple loc it just the
idea of passing something and knowing
that it we that Nano statute is going to
change and I just I just I just think
that's really awkward and I do want to
pass this bill I want to pass this bill
but I just want Amendment for next when
so we you get two weeks SC we're not
going to take it up for two weeks so and
then you know that the amendment will
take up the amendment two weeks from now
and then at that point um we then bring
it to the full
committee so I'm just at this point
we're not voting on it now I just wanted
how everybody feels about of that
Amendment yes representative I'm not on
the subcommittee but I did have a quick
question yes how did between the
licenses and the tiers how did this get
so complicated I tried to put a matri
together you'll never understand it
nobody understand did it just evolve
over time it seems so so onerous and
every time we can't solve a problem we
come up with a new
license like Band-Aids on top of
Band-Aids it just seems like very
complicated it's I always called it
Byzantine is my my adjective um I would
also say this is kind of job security
for
me the
only but and that's only because I've
been doing this for so long I think
businesses change every year business
business models change every
year moving
forward well I I would say I before I I
would always say okay it's this was the
only law that's the upside down law
where every every other law is
everything's legal until we say you
can't do it and and and create licenses
so you can't so we can take your license
away to stop you from doing but in this
case uh uh I did um after going through
my vacation rental and learning about
zoning that that that zoning and liquor
laws are very similar in the sense is
you that the zoning specifically tells
you what you can can't do and I and I
watched this firsthand in my town when
it was over a tire
warehouse okay which is T and that and
they and it went to the courts they they
they
went because uh the zoning allowed for
auto
repair and the issue was was Tire you
know but that said no tire you know
Warehouse was a tire was different it's
it's retail right it's not repair and
it's a tire and so they lost lost the
ability we lost our ability to have a
tire warehouse and
wrench but not not withstanding that
that um what makes our liquor laws so
convoluted and so complicated is that um
at the time when the three tier concept
which was to go after tide houses which
was definitely afraid of
a large Brewer like anheiser Bush taking
over the you know the marketplace and if
you go and and if example I give you if
you ever go to England and they and they
actually the licenses are are based on
the fact that they're not tide houses or
are tight houses you know they actually
have their whole license structures
around whether it's a it's a free I
don't know it's not free I forget the
name of the word that the Brit the
British have anybody know what that's
called what they the British they have
it uh um but anyways it's it's LIC and
and then so but that yeah they thought
it was fair fine that Guinness could own
their own bar and Guinness you know has
their own establishment and that's all
you're going to get is Guinness and
Guinness products
whereas um so for us you know we at that
time we said no we're not going to allow
that at all and um even though you know
I always was amazed when you go to the
airport and I see a Sam Adams restaurant
in the airport well that's just they're
licensing the name
you know right and so yeah they can sell
other than same Adams products in there
because they're just
selling right well then so well that's a
that's part of the three tier in anra
Bush they they're not going to sell you
anything else other than an anra Bush
product or inbev product at this point
but um so uh uh I it is true it's very
convoluted but I would say everything
comes down to the fact that be because I
call this this is a mother mayi so every
time someone comes over with a brilliant
idea of what to do and like we you know
we talked about um you know the one we
have this time where some guy is he's
he's he's making the product in Maine
and he wants to bring it in the
Hampshire and in a bottle or making it
here in New Hampshire and Bott so it's
just there's so many different things
that you never would have thought of and
and the one I always think going back
was when flag Hill first showed up here
and and he said you know was really
great you know it's a nightmare I I get
to distill this
you know John Stark vodka but I can't
sample it I can't taste it I can't do
anything and so then we start chipping
away a letting him be able to give
samples and B letting him eventually to
actually have the product on the Shelf
rather than say hope you like it but you
got to go down to the state Lor store to
buy it okay so yeah and every and then
when you take the three different and
then the other things that really makes
it complicated is that every different
kinds of at we have we have a different
tax
structure okay so you start out right
from the beginning where we had that we
we said beverage and we didn't decide
what a beverage was we just said
anything than 6% or less is a beverage
and we really didn't care about what was
in it and and we have this outrageously
low tax of 30 cents a gallon and then
you and then you go from there when you
say okay those guys wanted to do
something that was more than 6% oh my
God what are we going to do specialty
beers do we want to change the tax
structure no you know and then and then
you know the you know there was a period
of time it's I would say it happened
before me beer pubs did happen before me
and but there was a period of time where
you could not get wine in the grocery
stores you had to go to the liquor store
and I'm sure that was a quite a hurrah
to let go of that so so anyway that's
that's the reason why we have this
Byzantine system
and so I hope all of you will stay here
long enough so that you can you know be
as be an expert like me right or I would
even call myself an expert because I'm
constantly constantly saying what
exactly did what exactly is
so okay so we will take up Brew Pub and
that be prepared for an amendment that
will reduce uh 5,000 to
okay you
have yeah so we're not going to take any
action on that no I know but give you my
copy oh
what Bill what bill is this number why
did I what did
I it's okay we can do no I thought I had
my I thought I found
my okay we'll get a copy
okay all right 1540 relative to the
definition of full course meal and full
service restaurants for the purpose of
alcohol licensing this is this is my
bill and I worked with Danielle and came
up with a really good Amendment but I
don't have it yet so we'll just have to
move it to next time but Danielle was
totally on board I'm basically if you
guys see the bill I can tell you what
it's going to look like um so everything
that's new that defines Bill uh defines
the types of food that's going to be
deleted but we're also going to delete
what is deleted there that's so where it
says which ordinarily cannot be consumed
without using table wear that whole line
is going to remain um deleted and
then um in the new language at the
bottom there I'm going to
change at least um I'm going to take out
the 10 guests but I'm going to add in
like
with um keep keep keep 20 but the
amendment says with Liquor's approval to
go less than 20 20
seats right so we're talking on line 20
sorry yep so on line 20 right now it's
cross so I'm going to go back to having
the 20 there but and then add in a line
that says which is what the amendment I
had last week but we never got to it
said but then I spoke to Danielle s more
and we camp with a few more things and
then on line 23 where the sentence that
starts with the menu shall contain
multiple options so that's going to be
deleted as well it's just going to be
meals shall be readily available and
served to the table so that will but all
the crossed out stuff would stay there
so it's going to
be I think I I I don't know if she's in
the room but I really appreciated
working with her she was great and she
understands my intent and we worked a
lot on it we had a bunch of
conversations on it so I think we're
going to get to what I'm hoping to get
for without messing up Liquors
enforcement abilities so um the next
time I'll have this way in here
and thank you chairman I followed along
with um the notes from deputy chief
Elston and and uh that's consistent with
what okay she has come up with I like
the idea of figuring out exactly what is
the food you know the menu where the
food items are I really I do I do like
that the only thing I would add to this
is that uh we do have liquor rule on
this it's uh liquor uh rule
administrative Rule 50304 and that will
open up if this is passed right that
will open up 50304 for us to be able to
clearly Define some of that okay and
you're okay with doing it that way yeah
I think it'll work it sounds like that
would give them the flexibility her
concern with some my things which didn't
particularly concern me but she was
worried about just like the can of
Campbell Soup being served and counted
or something those sorts of things which
which um you know that's fine it's like
I'm not like married to that idea I was
just trying to make it as broad as
possible so we could make it easier for
businesses to start but um I think the
language as I work with her will still
do that because it's just a diversified
selection of food that gives that that's
more broad than having these definitions
so I think it still accomplishes what I
want hopefully the rule making doesn't
become so restrictive that we end up
having to come back with a bill like
this in the future but assuming that
doesn't happen then I'm fine with
it you can't just have a can of
soup I love toatoa soup and things you
you put the little pasta that in that
preparation if I put some pasta in the
soup I yes I I definitely think we want
to uh keep the tradition of food being
required but being prepared the key word
is being the preparation is Right
correct so
okay thank you okay good so we'll stay
stay tuned on that one all right uh
1582 um representative pusc moves uh
interim
study if you don't mind second this is
the one that we just took care of in in
51 so so you have this is 1582 yeah
so Che
please
okay we're all set all those in favor
say I 1 2 3 4 four five six okay six
zip okay relative to of allowing
distillation of hobby
Liquors
um I always pride of myself on being
consistent and since I've now thrown
that rule out with cannabis I'm now
ready to pass this bill can I can I back
backtrack y are you do you know what
just went on with this bill who are you
looking at the three in the front
they're waiting for the last bill oh
okay I know who they
are
okay um so I I'm I'm okay with just
passing this bill at this point um I
mean I was thinking should we put a
little disclaimer in there to let
consumers know that by the way there is
a federal law
but um I would was assured by the chief
that if if that were to occur that the
person would get a phone call from the
chief and tell them just stop
it
so other than that anybody else have any
other comments about this you going
ought to pass it ought to
pass yeah that's good what you going to
do a 16
John not to
pass what do you think repres are you
ready
to so this is hooch as opposed to
Hookah Hookah we'll get to hookah yeah
so this is this is hooch this is uh this
is moonshine okay we didn't vote we
didn't vot no we have not voted she's
she's I'm waiting for her to give a
response this oh 1624 now is what I want
to talk about yes right now that's the
that's the pending motion is I'm moving
a to pass right but she's talking about
something else uh no she said she was
just making a a
funny
okay anybody in the audience want to
tell me it's a bad
idea do you want to tell me it's
idea okay so we know that not everybody
thinks this is a good idea to pass it
but
yes you mentioned before that different
Liquors and different alcohols are are
taxed at a different rate correct do
these get taxed okay so the this the
first assumption is that is home
distilling so that means that the person
who is doing this is not selling
it if they sell it but no no that's then
they're violating our state law relative
to alcohol so that that then they needed
to get
license and and yes they would have
attack structure
okay all
right
right okay all those in favor of of P HB
1624 ought to pass please raise your
hand 1 two 3 four five
six that'll make all the Libertarians
happy okay I think I think we're all set
with the last one all right 1591 we
saved the best for last
right
um so we we have a Amendment right the
amendment do we know the amendment do I
my pile what's amendment number what's
the latest amendment number do
you you have right
here I have this right there oh no
that's we have an do you have an
amendment number remember we have
anything on Kristen do we have anything
on
wom in
coming you remember same
one
right so this is not one I told you to
put in the file or
anything
lot lined
out1
p
Del
chair
it's not in the
folder
okay so uh this was one that we had the
resolution done on Friday but because
Monday was the holiday it didn't get
done and I thought it was G to get done
by
now what's the amendment uh John so the
amendment been
REM yep on
page EXC page
original B1
33 yeah okay okay so I have was going to
add it to it but it turns out the Senate
has a bill they are going to uh extend
the
sunset okay okay so I was I'm I'm
guaranteed in my mind that they'll pass
that so will'll get that bill and at
that point we can decide whether we want
to extend the sunset whether we want to
stick a marijuana bill on
it uh we could do all kinds of things we
might when we get that so at this point
I decide not to
take so we're just going to take up the
St bill when it comes over and not no no
start again on the issue of Delta H
Delta we'll take that
out do with this guy um so like I said
we'll wait for the amendment I don't
know in terms given that it's not lunch
time yet so we can wait a little
bit how are we going to find out
it
is synthetic
THC made from H but it's made from H H
so it's not so is it so it's legal so
it's legal uh and what I what I was
considering was to um legalize it and
have the the tobacco people yeah
so um
but the smoke
Musketeers so at this point you know
um
Bruce
what
okay so unfortunately uh ol miss it was
a miscommunication so that is not going
to happen today so we'll put take that
up on on March 5th sorry to bring you in
here all the time but I'm sure you're
just really entertained to watch this
watch this process what's the sausage
being
made yeah sorry about that
okay
you want to her over and have lunch I
will I definitely want to
go
for
all right let's just do it all right uh
all in order okay and I might need the
bill
so John I might need yeah oh you that's
great having you with my computer all
right 11 29 relative to the authority to
vote by
proxy in a condo
association so this one was okay the
only problem the only question we needed
to
add
um for the one lobbyist in the
room okay which we want we want to add
only
119 it's
11:29 you have have the bill here yeah I
I have I have okay so where where is
this then this is section
two p no page two page
two oh I see here's here's an amendment
proposal
where's that from I don't I don't
know9 it was handed out so I stuck it
in
okay so I I have a sing this is
represented M's language so so let's
just solve this first one okay uh this
section okay so that so we wanted to
add on D are you following along so you
might
yeah hi who who do you
represent
grimas okay so you're just watching for
her okay yeah Jody used to do that in
the past you you sent her
mother okay so
um it's it's
uh the
D it says this where it
says uh this says something
different kind of is compromise of time
sharing interest this okay so so in the
in the bill as written
says this paragraph shall not apply if
the condominium is comprised of time
sharing interests
only
and so you wrote this
section shall not apply and I'm looking
on this piece of paper so this was you
must have worked from her
Amendment
yeah does she have an amendment no she
didn't even have an amendment this was
that was just hand it out this a wing
wing it
yeah so are this
last should be a section or this par
paragraph seems like the wrong word
so so good afternoon Mr chairman um for
the record my name is Heidi croll I work
at Gallagher cahandar tra and I'm here
today representing Arta which is the
American Resort Development Associate
so I was working off of an amendment
that representative Aly presented to
your committee on January 16th okay um
which I I don't have that with me I
apologize um and
um which did solve one issue between the
as introduced um and the amendment we
needed to change the word from I think
it was paragraph to section um and I
think we got that part squared away
um but did but on page two um d as you
were mentioning it says this section
shall not apply if the condominium is
comprised of time share interest only
and we are asking to remove the word
only um which representative Aly agreed
with
um okay so so chrisen you're working
from you have the original bill as
introduced yeah okay so you see the word
only at the end of that sentence so we
want to delete that word
only yeah and then and then instead of
saying this paragraph should say this
section so I'm going to mark up here go
ahead you stay you stay in
any if you you're if you see that
section then you're looking at this
piece of paper
version
know9 okay okay so then the other thank
you Mr chairman okay great so we solved
your problem okay so the other section
she had a new SE the complete text of
all the voting articles must be included
in the properly noticed meeting agenda
voting on these articles amended during
the meeting must be deferred until the
next properly noticed meeting and proper
notice must be delivered to all
condominium owners in accordance with
the provision yep I like
that I don't have a problem with
that and actually
pass so this this is in the amendment
this was in the amendment that she
handed out at the hearing
22 uh because we have one member of our
committee who is anal and keeps
all
we're we're not we're we'll have an
amendment yeah I'm fine with it I'm fine
with it
good at we're we'll take these up uh in
March March actually a week
later
yeah put the order in
now okay
that's fine oh no no no in March okay we
this is you know what I'm what I'm
struggling with is because we don't have
the folder to see who was for or against
it so I'm relying on you John was there
anybody against
against okay I don't want to see that I
so the what do they cond they were all
they all supported yeah okay did Dario
supported it all right that's that's
what I need to know so everybody had it
was okay with
it
um so there's no problem right there was
nobody needed an amendment no problem
with this
bill
Okay who wants to be the condo
King who who who has a condo I there we
go Herbert I don't want to
Dot
Krypto in
there okay so Keith you were on the
condo board right uh yes if you want me
to do it I will do it thank you all
right
okay
like
okay okay 1172 Keith H seconded by r
pres Herbert um who ought to
pass on 1172 any discussion on the
motion seeing none all those okay who's
on this
subcommittee
okay am Cole Cole need be replace if
Herbert melier and spear are here yes
okay so I need I need a a I need a
republican okay oh there she is and
representative post post
okay all right all those all those in
favor say I or raise your hand those
opposed it's moved
unanimously six six is it because yes
six
okay beautiful all right moving right
along
have
right okay what's the next one
okay okay one
page okay so anybody for anybody where
were people for and against it
more like section 39 not
32 that mean yeah oh
b39 so he was suggesting that it should
be amended
to more lik not 32 but this says
b39 maybe s section
32 that's that's what
I that a no shall more than a majority
vote be required to amend bylaws by
regarding this section in sitting of a
utility service or installation oh yeah
that was the pool was that the
insurance no that was something
else not
section whatever that condo law is by
single doesn't make any sense
this is a bad
Bill I yeah I remember yeah I don't
think I was too crazy about this
one do we want to inter yeah itl it or
interim study it it it okay who's gonna
you which of you two are going to make
the motion which
one of spear okay
okay all those in favor of inexp to
legislate raise your
hand two three four five six everybody
okay representative spear seconded by
representative Sullivan oh no it can't
be representative
Ammon okay
okay now
approval yeah I don't think I like this
one at
all provide that no special assessments
for capital expenditure improvements
that exceed 5% of the budgeted gross
expenses shall be allowed without
approval of the unit Owners
Association it's a big deal Bill broh
what's what do you got for notes on this
oneou
cou okay no maintenance
done
right just put a
cap yeah no that
she she was going on about how her
Association had totally mismanaged
yeah and and uh in terms of the
improvements they didn't do in the
improvements and right and then now they
have to pay now they have to pay so much
yeah more so I we can't pass this I I
would say either interim study or kill
it let's do inter study
okay yeah
stud interm
study wait a minute I just I want to
understand amendment when I read that
Amendment
um basically and I remember the
conversation with people you up talking
about incompetent management right right
well she she was going on and she was
used to be on the board she was a board
member and then she was going on how
they didn't they didn't they didn't do
the improvements that needed to get done
weren't they weren't prop maintaining
things and then and so then they they
were had to do this Capital Improvements
and she was opposed to it
well what it says here the way I read it
is that in order to go
beyond improvements that exceed 5% of
the budget of grow expenses shall be
allowed without approval of the inment
association so in other words you can't
they can't do what they did again you
know what I mean they spent a lot of
money and then didn't do what they were
said no I I don't remember that I my
memory was they hadn't spent any money
and then they were doing a special
assessment because they needed to get
caught up to do these Capital
Improvements right for 10 years no
maintenance was done yeah so no Capital
Improvements and we we asked her I said
don't you guys put money away for
Capital Improvements what they do with
the money yeah what
and what
uh and and where did the money go for
the cast improvements but evidently they
weren't putting the money away so it was
really mismanagement and she was blaming
the management company rather than the
board which the board is the ones really
responsible not the management company
management company was just trying to
appease the board who didn't want to
spend the money in the first
place um there's something here budgeted
gross expenses so that's
that they have
budgeted and what I read is
that no other
assessment that exceeds 5% of the
budgeted gross expenses shall be allowed
without the approval of the unit Owners
Association so in other words to me
they're looking to
avoid spending money that are of putting
budgets capital expenditure budgets and
then doing anything and then coming back
later and saying oh we need this
stuff and and the uh I mean maybe it's
just not written right right well
because you would say that anything
anytime it comes to the unit owners do
vote on it no matter what right so they
took a they took a vote on a budgeted
gross expense on a line
item but but according to the narrative
the
people the what are they call
condominium you
know board no not the board we always
have a man the management firm didn't do
it in other words they got the money but
they didn't do anything so here's here's
what I'm doing we don't have to vote on
this today yeah we can put this off till
till March but you need to do some
homework and figure out whether we what
this bill really
means I think just in stud because we we
have a pretty good management outfit and
is not a problem that we face right so
maybe if I ask and and I urge you to
watch the
Youtube Youtube watch the
hearing mean what I just said no not
today back
then can we just or we can do inter room
study didn't write
it interim study yeah with me okay
interim study and if you find out
differently then we'll take we can
reconsider to my my board and say but
let's do inter room study we're doing
inter room study now and then you go to
your board and if so then we can bring
it back up if they tell you okay okay so
representative am and second by
representative Herbert moves in room
study okay motion
clear all right all those in favor say I
I those opposed
moved
unanimously
number
exactly I actually had
that all right 1357 relative to condo
board
meetings got to start writing notes oh
good
perfect we do it we do
it oh yeah this is no good yeah this was
not bad okay representative
Herbert second by representative Ammon
moves in experient to
legislate yeah because to tell to tell
them a board to do monthly is tell a
board do they have to do it
monthly I mean I think they should have
it within 60 days I think it's quarterly
most people do it quarterly do we want
to do inter because it's we do it
quarterly and then you get all the
members get the uh
report